if you kill an oracle Envoy you might
pick up their white flesh thin strips
that are taken from a bloodless creature
it's our only clue as to what these
creatures actually are like underneath
for the envoys are densely wrapped in
several layers of cloth their headpiece
reveals that no one knows what the cloth
hides but some have claimed to have
heard a faint whimpering from inside
whatever they are they play these giant
golden horns and it is said that when
the Oracle envoys appear playing these
pipes they do so to Herald the arrival
of a new God or H which is good timing
considering you just showed up and a lot
is about to change but the Oracle envoys
don't just appear in Lane delt they also
appear in Nicholas halictree in this
place the demigod mikola was expected to
become a new God for a new age but then
he was ripped from his cocoon his story
here seems to be at an end so why then
do the oracles persist with their song
well what if nikola's story really is
only just beginning maybe the oracles
have foreseen his return